[Applause]
from east to west from north to south
India has seen protests big and small
many extremely noisy Indians have come
out in large numbers angry at the law
passed last month granting citizenship
to people from persecuted religious
minorities from neighboring countries
but not if they're Muslim opposition
politicians civil society activists
young and old and many students have
been at the forefront but peaceful
demonstrations have turned violent in
states mainly controlled by the ruling
BJP party of Prime Minister Narendra
Modi police have been blamed for
numerous deaths and injuries in Auto
Pradesh the death of this young
restaurant worker walking home after a
shift caused outrage and prompted an
investigation into police violence
protests have taken various forms in
song and art of these creative minds
gather to explain how they feel about
the events of the past few weeks as
Indians not necessarily this or that
community of caste or religion I just
stood together in Kolkata opposition
politicians have made their position
clear regardless of religion they say
the reality of the National Register of
citizens the NRC and the citizenship
Amendment bill the CA B is becoming
clearer
thanks to Modi and char we had detention
camps and in those detention camps 60%
of people in those detention camps were
Bengali Hindus so this entire story
about NRC and CA being is not religion
centric at all it affects everybody
it affects Indian citizens Prime
Minister Narendra Modi is clear about
what the citizenship law is the Muslims
who were born on Indian soil or whose
ancestors are children of Mother India
they have nothing to do with the
citizenship law or the National Register
of citizens neither are the Muslims
being sent to any detention centers nor
are there any detention centers brothers
and sisters this is a white lie
and it's here at India's Supreme Court
that a final decision will be made the
Chief Justice of India will hear almost
60 petitions objecting to this the
citizenship law the government will get
its chance to explain the details of the
legislation and then we expect to hear
long and lengthy argument the debate
will center around whether the law is
discriminatory or whether it fails to
live up to the spirit of India's secular
democratic constitution until a verdicts
announced millions whose Indian identity
and their right to live here is being
questioned we'll continue to fear for
their future
Sahil Rawat al Jazeera New Delhi